we're talking all about kubernetes
coding Enterprise functionality and
serverless welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news we talked about some of the
announcements at Google app next but
there was so much to show there's no way
we could fit it into just one video
we've compiled a huge list of
announcements for you to check out and
see which ones you can use to start
building with today speaking of which
here are some ones that we're really
excited about first up is one that you
may have missed cloud code cloud code is
a set of plugins for IntelliJ and Visual
Studio code that brings automation and
assistance to every phase of the
software development lifecycle from
local development environments right to
the cloud and with integrated command
line tools like scaffold jib and cube
CTL under the hood cloud code gives you
everything you need for developing with
kubernetes and the manage google
kubernetes engine give it a try
speaking of manage kubernetes did you
catch the gke advance announcement we've
just published the first blog post in a
series that talks about what gke
advanced offers think of it as the gke
you're already familiar with but with a
bunch of enterprise requested features
such as automatic vertical pod auto
scaling and node auto provisioning more
integrations and an enhanced SLA give
you the flexibility to choose the right
level of manage kubernetes and to launch
our application on Google cloud now if
you're using cribben ideas to help
orchestrate but you still want the best
to utilize serverless Kay native is
worth checking out Google developer
advocate Metta optimal has a github repo
that walks you through setting up gke
with sto and Kay native then covers the
three main components serving eventing
and building this is a great way to
start exploring how service can help run
your application without worrying about
how the underlying logistics work and
best of all you get some hands-on Kay
native experience if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link have any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you